boy the way glenn miller played
songs that made the hit parade
that character was based on your dad yes
that character was based on my dad well
the poor blood is the same let me ask
you this
how come they ain't got no swedes in the
mafia
i was the meathead and uh he was archie
and those in that context
wait a minute meathead you said that not
me
from all in the family and the
jeffersons to good times the facts of
life and different strokes norman has
produced some of the most iconic shows
in history tackling once taboo subjects
like race abortion and sexuality in
changing the face of television forever
for someone like me it was seeing
the african-american characters at a
time where there weren't a lot of
african-americans on tv and we see for
one of the first times on television
this interracial couple
what matters is not what passes across
our minds it's how we live our lives
together
how is that pushing that through it's
just the most glorious ride
in the history of rise
george clooney and regina king got their
starts on norman lear shows and yes
that's an 11 year old janet jackson
making her debut on another
groundbreaking sitcom good times turn on
the television set and i'll be right
home okay but this is better than tv
who came up with dynamite dino man
it was the actor
jimmy walker who gave us his dynamite
uh and that became dynamite
how did you come up with facts i am the
father of five daughters one son and and
having been married a couple of times
and uh
i don't know there was a richness of
material it's all together different
this picture is spectacular we visited
with norman in his production office
where the trailblazer told us he has no
regrets about any of his work including
the controversial episode of maude that
aired in 1972. just tell me walter that
i'm doing the right thing
not having the baby
in the privacy of our own lives you're
doing the right thing
what do you remember about that and now
just the post about
what we have going on now
i mean
that line is as important to me today as
it was in the night in the evening
we shot it in front of 300 people but
yes ma'am and the privacy of your life
and your family and
as you see your future and that child's
future
nobody else can make this decision it's
yours
at a century old norman is still
breaking new ground reboots of his shows
who's the boss with alyssa milano and
mary hartman mary hartman are in the
works and he's the oldest ever emmy
nominee in history his collab with jimmy
kimmel live in front of a studio
audience the facts of life and different
strokes is up for two awards this year
what you talking about willis
the fact that he's still here to witness
uh the love and energy that people have
had for what he's put together i think
that's the biggest that's the biggest
birthday present they can get but norman
and his producing partner brett miller
aren't done yet the decision that just
happened with with the supreme court
might be a mod episode um
you know we we will certainly
talk to jimmy about that jimmy kimmel
but it's definitely something that we've
talked about that interests us
now the legendary producer whose library
of classic shows can be seen on freev is
being honored with an epic birthday
celebration norman lear 100 years of
music and laughter airing september 22nd
on abc and of course we couldn't let
norman's 100th birthday go by without
getting him a present oh i am so glad to
have this
for a milestone like that you got to get
an e.t sweatshirt oh i love it this is
mine that's yours
i i love it thank you thank you
[Music]